I'm curious
what do you think
drives you
now because you have had so much success
for a long time but I can tell you take
this very seriously and you are very
driven is that your dad's work ethic
yeah that was instilled in me at a young
age just like work you got to work you
gotta go out I mean I was working at
Fuddruckers when I was 14 years old that
was one of my first jobs and never
really stopped working since since I was
14. so yeah that definitely comes from
my father
and uh you know I don't know for me I
felt like it was
extremely fun coming up through the
clubs and getting my first spot on your
show and and and doing these things for
the first time no one really knowing who
I was it was exciting now it's a little
the pressure is a little a little bit
higher to you know kind of maintain the
standard you know right keep the jokes
as good as they were you know that's the
whole thing it's like
you know I did I did a comedy special
that came out on Netflix this year and I
got kind of like people like yeah it's
not as good as your it's not as good as
this you're not as good as that so that
never really happened to me before and
not that I'm sitting there looking at
you know what people are saying but if
you got to be a fool not to like put
your ear to the ground and go is this
hitting with people I mean are people
kind of getting this and trying
something different you know I I
normally am a physical comedian so this
one I want like let me throw it back to
the Rat Pack and wear a tuxedo I don't
know where a tuxedo because it kind of
hinders hinders my movement I'm not as
comfortable but I'm like yeah let me do
something different you know right and
um you know I got some some backlash of
oh he's not as physical as he once was
that's I'm 50. no no sympathy in this
room
we all fought in the Korean War everyone
in this room I died in the crew yeah
and as a ghost you're old
um he's an old out of shape ghost
ghost with a low back problem
but you know no but I mean that's the
other thing too is uh
um to me the biggest driving thing is
which I I know you yeah
is
if someone's disappointed with something
I've done it makes me physically ill
like
if they're disappointed in my comedic
attempt or if they're disappointed uh it
makes me so upset that I work hard to
try and make sure that doesn't happen
yeah now it can still happen but it's
it's that fear of failure which
uh doesn't diminish you'd think it would
diminish and it doesn't and if I'm
someplace and it's a small group and I'm
supposed to go up and give a toast or
something I get anxious and if I feel
like the toast wasn't good enough and
people like what are you talking about a
toast you know it's
you know what are you worried about that
for I don't think that goes away no
that's with you I could relate to that
and my my kid just had a birthday party
and I got on the microphone to kind of
like because we were going to play these
games these old school games at my kids
birthday party so I got on the
microphone hey everybody
I got off
oh my God
I just I just felt like I let them down
you know professional professional
comedian
and while you're as good as last time
your kid's birthday party all you're
doing is saying the pin the tail and the
donkey's over here on the right
and the dunking board is over there on
the bouncy castle you know that's all
you're there to do
ah no I should have started with the
bouncy
then you elevate to the donkey
but no I know what you're talking about
because so much of comedy and Performing
and writing is choices and I'm always
second-guessing the choices uh
afterwards and it it's the same thing it
doesn't matter how small the stakes are
you know you can still beat yourself up
about it
absolutely and you know now that we're
talking about this this this really has
happened last week my daughter's
birthday and my wife and I went into I
guess uh the parents read to the class
on on the the day of the birthday of the
kids so we walk in and we had our
daughter's favorite book and the plan
was my wife was going to read half of it
and I was gonna read half of it so my
wife starts to read the book and she's
burning through the book I just like
and I've never read the kids before it's
a group of six-year-olds I've never read
to them before I started getting into
the book and then I'm starting like
incorporating the kids and doing my own
lines from the book we hate Veronica
don't we yeah
and uh that's I told the teacher I go
I'd love to read to the kids every
Friday
can I be a TA yeah but uh
I just think it's innate it's in us to
if we get a group of people I think it's
innate for us to like
this is a true story it's so funny you
bring that up I uh this we're gonna have
to hang out and get wine I'm sorry
because there's too much there's too
much
Common Ground here but uh when my
daughter was younger I it was read to
the kids day and I went over and this
was to the over to the school you
remember this and I went over there and
I had a story to read and the story I
remembered looking at it it's only like
nine pages long because the kids are
little and I was like there's not much
to work with here I remember thinking
that like flipping through it like all
I've got is nine pages so what is I go
to sit down and they go okay now you
know Nev's dad Mr O'Brien and I sit down
and I notice that there's this like
stuffed Dragon right behind me whose
face is kind of looking at me so I kept
doing these physical takes before I even
read the book I was like well kids nice
to see you and oh god oh
and the kids started laughing really
hard
so I kept doing all this with the
dragon and it was and it was doing
really well and the teacher the teacher
came up the teacher came up I'll never
forget and she put her hand on my
shoulder and said you just read the book
you just read oh my God and I was
looking at her like you kidding
chilling you don't step on that